ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
THERE ARE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WHAT THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BE ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE?
WILL BE LET IN FOR THIS MORNING
BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AS WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
THIS BLESSING IS BY JOHN
O'DONOGHUE.
MAY WE RECOGNIZE IN OUR LIVES
THE PRESENCE POWER AND DELIGHTS
OF OUR SOUL.
MAY WE REALIZE THAT WE ARE NEVER
ALONE.
THAT ARE SO IN ITS BRIGHTNESS
AND BELONGING.
CONNECTS US INTIMATELY WITH THE
RHYTHM OF THE UNIVERSE.
MAY WE RESPECT OUR OWN
INDIVIDUALITY AND DIFFERENCE.
MAY WE REALIZE THAT THE SHAPE OF
ARE SO IS UNIQUE.
THOSE WE HAVE A SPECIAL DESTINY
HERE.
BUT BEHIND THE FACADE OF OUR
LIVES THERE IS SOMETHING GOODS
BEAUTIFUL AND ETERNAL HAPPENING.
MAYBE LEARN TO SEE OURSELVES
WITH THE SAME DELIGHTS PRIDE AND
EXPECTATION.
WITH WHICH ARE MYSTERIOUS GOD.
PLEASE US IN EVERY MOMENT.
A MAN.
PUT YOUR HAND OVER YOUR HEARTS
FLAYED IN JOHN.
AND RECITE WITH ME THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
AND WRONG [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOW WE WILL MOVE TO PRIVILEGES
AT THE FLOOR.
SENATOR -- SENATOR PORCHES ARE
YOU PREPARED 2% SR.
TWENTY SIX AND HE WILL BE DOING
THAT FROM THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR GORGEOUS RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL BLINDED VETERANS DAY.
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY
SIX OUR COLLEAGUES RECOGNIZING
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH AS NATIONAL.
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH AS NATIONAL
BLINDED VETERANS DAY.
TODAY MARKS THE SEVENTY FOURTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE BLINDED
VETERANS ASSOCIATION.
AND THEIR EFFORTS TO IMPROVE TO
IMPROVE REHABILITATION SERVICES.
EDUCATION AND BENEFITS FOR OUR
NATION'S BLINDED VETERANS.
THEY ARE THE ONLY NATIONAL
VETERANS SERVICE ORGANIZATION
CHARTER BY THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS.
WHICH IS EXCLUSIVELY DEDICATED
TO ASSISTING AMERICA'S BLINDED
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX SIX
TO HONOR OUR NATION'S VETERANS
WHO HAVE SACRIFICED SO MUCH FOR
OUR FREEDOMS.
AND TO RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO
SUFFER FROM VISUAL IMPAIRMENT.
AND BRING AWARENESS TO THE
EFFORTS TO HELP THEM REGAIN
THEIR INDEPENDENCE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS RESOLUTION.
ANY ANY OTHER ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY OZ MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL.
BY WERE JUST.
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RISE OF BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI HI HILL.
HI HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY.
JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AND BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI MORRELL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE AND BY WHAT COUNTY.
I WIENER HI WILK [inaudible]
HI HI.
SEC A CENTER BOARD JUST MOVES
THE CALL US -- BRIDGES I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A GAS TO FOR
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I'D I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE.
EDWARD CRANE EDWARD CRANE IS A
VOLUNTEER TEAM MEMBER WITH THE
BLINDED VETERANS ASSOCIATION.
MR CRANE MADE THE TRIP -- TO
SACRAMENTO HERE TODAY FROM
CLOVIS CALIFORNIA AND IF
COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD PLEASE
GIVE HIM A WARM WELCOME
.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WILL CONTINUE
MOVING ON WITH IT WITH TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS.
THAT MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
NOW MEMBERS WILL BE MOVING TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR MARCH TWENTY FIFTH
THROUGH THE TWENTY EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
NOW MOVING TOWARDS CONSIDERATION
THE DAILY FILE -- SECOND READING
FILE ITEMS NUMBER ONE THROUGH
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY NINE WITH
THE MEMBERS TO EIGHTY ONE WITH
THE MOMENT SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY NINE THREE EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE SENATE BILL THIRTY
WITH THE MOMENTS SENATE BILL TWO
FOR TAKING HIM SECRETARY SECOND
READING WILL BE DEEMED READ.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO SENATE RE --
SENATE THIRD READINGS TODAY WILL
TWELVE THIRTEEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY THREE SO.
WHILE ITEM TWELVE IS S. R.
TWENTY FOUR CENTER DRAWS SO ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT YES I AM.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR THERE ALSO RELATIVE TO
SISTER CHAVEZ DAY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES.
I AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO CAUCUS I RISE
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
SENATE RESOLUTION.
TWENTY FOUR WHICH ACKNOWLEDGES
THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF SAYS SIDE
EACH JOB IS.
BORN ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST.
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN SAYS SIZE
LIVE WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXAMPLE OF HOW ONE PERSON CAN
IMPACT ALL OF OUR LIVES.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE.
I WAS PICKING CROPS FROM THE DAY
THAT I COULD WALK.
ALL THE WAY THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL.
NUMBER SEVEN IN A FAMILY OF
ELEVEN WITH PERRANCE ALL WORKED
AS MIGRANT FARMWORKER FAMILY.
FROM THE LEXICAL TO OREGON.
EVERYTHING FROM COTTON TO GRAPES
TO PEACHES TO PAIR YOU NAME IT
WE PICKED IT.
AND I WAS ALWAYS AMAZED AT HOW
MY FATHER WAS SO PROUD OF HIS
WORK.
AND EVEN LET US GET AWAY WITH
DOING SHABBY WORK.
AND I ALWAYS THOUGHT TO MYSELF.
WHY IT'S JUST A PEACH IT'S JUST
A OF A YOU KNOW A GREAT WHAT THE
HECK IS THE MATTER WITH TAKING
SOME SHORT CUTS?
AND HE WAS VERY STRINGENT ABOUT
DOING IT RIGHT HE LOVED.
THE WORK YOU LOVE THE FEELS HE
THOUGHT IT WAS A VERY VERY.
EXTRAORDINARY THING FOR HIM TO
DO THAT.
I OF COURSE THOUGHT ABOUT HOW DO
I GET OUT OF HERE.
WHAT'S THE FASTEST WAY TO GET
OUT OF WORKING IN THE FIELDS.
BECAUSE OF THE HEAT.
BECAUSE OF THE COLD.
BECAUSE OF THE WORKING
CONDITIONS WERE JUST THE WORST.
AND WHEN SAYS ARE CHAVEZ AND THE
FARMWORKERS MOVEMENT BEGAN
[inaudible]
I LEARNED.
AND SET ASIDE VALIDATED MY
FATHER AND OUR FAMILIES LOVE OF
DOING THIS WORK.
THE SIDE LIVED AND RESPONSE AND
DEPENDED ON THE POWER OF
SOLIDARITY BUT HE TAUGHT US THAT
WE WERE WORTH MORE.
THAN THE INSTRUMENTS OF THE WORK
THAT WE DID THAT WE WERE HUMAN
BEINGS AND WE DESERVE THE
RESPECT FOR THIS HARD WORK.
SO HE RELIED ON SOLIDARITY WHEN
FARMWORKERS THEMSELVES WHEN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ASKING FOR
SUPPORT.
IN CITIES AND WAYS THAT THEY HAD
NEVER KNOWN BEFORE THEY LEFT
THEIR SMALL TOWNS AND THEY
TRAVELED ALL THE WAY TO CANADA
TO NEW YORK TO BOSTON.
PLACES THEY HAD NEVER BEEN
BEFORE AND EVERYWHERE THEY WENT
NUNS AND PRIESTS AND UNION
LEADERS AND ENVIRONMENTALISTS
AND COMMUNITY LEADERS.
REGULAR MOMS IN THE URBAN AREAS
OPENED UP THEIR HOMES.
AND JOIN THEM ON THE PICKET
LINES.
IN SEPTEMBER NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
SAYS SIDE LED A SUCCESSFUL FIVE
YEAR STRIKE.
AND BOYCOTT THAT RALLIED
MILLIONS OF SUPPORTERS WHO THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS HE FORGED
THE NATIONAL COALITION OF UNIONS
AND CHURCHES AND STUDENTS AND
CONSUMERS.
HE UNDERSTOOD THAT THE ONLY WAY
FOR THE POOR AND EXPLOITED
FARMWORKERS WITH TO HAVE AND
CREATE THEIR OWN UNION.
THE FIRST PROHIBITION OF A
PESTICIDE IN THE FEELS TO
PROTECT BOTH THE FARMWORKERS AND
US AS CONSUMERS WAS THROUGH A
UNION CONTRACT IT WAS A
PROHIBITION OF DDT.
THROUGH THE ACTS OF NON VIOLENCE
BOYCOTT.
AND STRIKES AND FAST HE
EMPOWERED THE MOLDS VULNERABLE
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE.
A TODAY'S SISTERS AND BROTHERS
THE ROLE OF FARMWORKERS IS JUST
AS VITAL TO THE ECONOMY OF
CALIFORNIA AS IT WAS WHEN SAYS
SIDE AND THE FARMWORKERS BEGAN
THE STRUGGLE.
OUR FARMWORKERS FEED OUR STATE
AND OUR NATION THROUGH THEIR
HARD WORK THEY ARE THE BACKBONE
OF THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY.
ON BEHALF OF HIS LEGACY WE SEEK
SO SHE'LL AND ECONOMIC EQUALITY
TODAY [inaudible]
TODAY. FOR FARMWORKERS FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE SIDE CHAVEZ USED TO SAY WE
CANNOT SEEK ACHIEVEMENT FOR
OURSELVES AND FORGET ABOUT THE
PROGRESS AND PROSPERITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
OUR AMBITIONS MUST BE BROAD
ENOUGH TO INCLUDE THE
ASPIRATIONS AND THE NEEDS OF
OTHERS FOR THEIR SAKES AND FOR
OUR OWN.
THIS IS A BROTHERS I RISE TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF MY MY MOTHER MY
FATHER MY SISTERS MY BROTHERS
ALL FARMWORKERS.
LET'S CONTINUE OUR WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THEM IN MIND.
WITH THAT I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
IN CELEBRATING THE LEGACY.
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND INFLUENTIAL
LEADERS OF OUR NATION SAYS SIDE
EACH CHAVEZ I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT GLASS YES.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS SO
SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
I WANT TO THANK MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
THAT REALLY COMPELLING.
TRIBUTE.
TO THE DEDICATION OF SAYS HER
CHAVEZ IN.
HIS LEGACY AND THE ON GOING WORK
THAT PEOPLE COMMITTED TO HIS
VISION.
CONTINUE TO PURSUE TODAY.
I HAD THE GREAT HONOR OF WORKING
IN THE U. F. W. LEGAL DEPARTMENT.
HAD A LOT OF CONTACT WITH SAY
SON INTO LOTUS AND OTHER LEADERS
OF THE UNION.
AND THE MOST REMARKABLE.
TRADE I THINK THAT I CARRY.
WHICH I LEARNED FROM SAY SAID.
THIS IS A MAN WITH AN EIGHTH
GRADE EDUCATION.
HE SERVED IN THE US NAVY.
WHEN HE CAME BACK FROM HIS
SERVICE IN THE NAVY?
HE AND HIS AT THE TIME
GIRLFRIEND HELEN.
WENT TO A MOVIE THEATER IN
DELANO.
AND WE'RE TOLD THEY HAD TO SIT
IN THE BACK OF THE THEATER.
HE WAS IN HIS NAVY UNIFORM.
WHEN HE WAS TOLD HE HAD TO SIT
AT THE BACK OF THE THEATER?
pMOMENTS.
IN THE SHAPING OF HIS CHARACTER
AND HIS VISION.
THE MAN WITH A BURNING DESIRE.
TO SERVE IN TO LEAD IN A
SELFLESS MANNER.
AND WHILE OPPONENTS WOULD ARGUE
THAT HE WAS LIVING IN LUXURY UP
IN THE PIES AND DRIVING GOLDING
CADILLACS.
I SAW HOW HE LIVED.
I SAW HOW HE SACRIFICED.
IN WE JOINED IN THE FAST.
IN HIS THIRTY SIX DAY FAST OF
WATER ONLY. TO BRING ATTENTION.
TO THE DAMAGE BEING CAUSED BY
PESTICIDES NOT JUST TO
FARMWORKERS BUT IN RURAL AREAS.
MANY FEEL THAT THIS FAST.
LED TO HIS SHORTENED LIFESPAN
BECAUSE OF DAMAGE TO HIS ORGANS
THAT WAS YOUR REVERSIBLE -- BUT
SAY SAID HIS BROTHER RICHARD
DELORES.
THE FOUNDERS OF THIS UNION.
DID IT PERSON BY PERSON FIELD BY
FIELD ANY LOOK AT THE POWER
DISPARITY.
HE ORGANIZED A GROUP OF
IMMIGRANTS.
MANY WITHOUT LEGAL STATUS IN
THIS COUNTRY WORKING FOR MINIMUM
WAGE OR LESS -- OFTEN MUCH OF
THE PAYCHECK BEING DIVERTED TO
PAY FOR SUBSTANDARD HOUSING.
WATER FOOD -- BUILT AN
ORGANIZATION.
THAT THROUGH THE POWER OF
NONVIOLENCE BROUGHT.
THE MOST POWERFUL [inaudible]
CORPORATE AGRICULTURISTS TO A
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
AND TO ME ONE OF THE IMAGES THAT
I LOVE TO CARRY.
IS THAT FARM WORKER CALLED ME
TODAY.
OF ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES TO
THE WORK FORCE WOMEN.
NEGOTIATING WITH THE LAWYERS
FROM CHICAGO AND LOS ANGELES
REPRESENTING AGRIBUSINESS.
AND BRINGING A QUALITY TO THAT
NEGOTIATION BY REQUIRING.
THE LAWYERS FOR THE COMPANIES TO
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
INTERPRETATION AND THEN THE
CAUCUS SING.
OF THE WOMEN NEGOTIATORS IN
HAMMERING OUT CONTRACTS THAT
BROUGHT A MODICUM NOT ONLY OF
JUSTICE IN TERMS OF WAGES AND
WORKING CONDITIONS.
IT IS MY GOOD FRIEND MENTIONED
THERE WAS SOMETHING MORE THAN
THE WAGES THE WORKING CONDITIONS
IT WAS THE DIGNITY. FOR THE WORK
IT WAS THE DIGNITY AND RESPECT
FOR THE SACRIFICE OF THE LIVE SO
I JUST WANT TO JOIN.
IN.
ADDING MY NAME IN SUPPORT TO THE
DAY OF RECOGNITION.
OF SISTER CHAVEZ HIS BIRTHDAY
MARCH THIRTY FIRST -- A DAY OF
SERVICE.
IN ONE OF HIS QUOTES.
WE MEASURE OURSELVES AT THE END.
NOT BY WHAT WE ACQUIRE.
THE SERVICE THAT WE GIVE.
SO VIVA CESAR CHAVEZ THE SICK
POINTING.
COULD ASSIST.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING.
SENATOR RUBIO.
GOOD MORNING PRESIDENTE MEMBERS
I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS AND SUPPORT OF AS FAR
TWENTY FOUR AS OUR COOK.
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES STATED
CESAR CHAVEZ WAS A GREAT LEADER
AND REALLY DID TAKE CARE OF A
LOT OF VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ARE CESAR CHAVEZ WORK EVERY DAY
TO FIVE FOR THE DIGNITY OF
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS.
MY FATHER BEING ONE OF THOSE AS
A LATINA WHO RECENTLY DISCOVERED
MY ANCESTRAL CONNECTION TO
JUDAISM I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE JEWISH CONNECTION
TO THE LABOR MOVEMENT AS WELL.
SURE ENOUGH WHEN CESAR CHAVEZ
STARTED ORGANIZING TO FIGHT THE
OPPRESSION OF LET YOU KNOW
FARMWORKERS.
MANY JEWISH LEADERS ROLLS TO HIS
SIDE IN SOLIDARITY SEVERAL ARE
TO DOCK A RABBI'S URGE THEIR
CONGREGATION NOT TO BUY.
NON UNION GRAPES DECLARING THEM
OSHITA MEANING ON CLEAN BECAUSE
THEY CAME FROM EXPLOITED WORKERS
TRAGIC THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
MAN FREEMAN WAS THE FIRST PERSON.
TO LOSE THEIR LIFE IN A FARM
WORKER PICKET LINE SHE WAS A
COLLEGE STUDENT FROM BOSTON WHO
TRAVEL TO FLORIDA. TO JOIN A
STRIKE AGAINST TALISMAN SUGAR
COMPANY AND WAS KILLED BY A
TRUCK THE CRASH THE PICKET LINE.
TODAY AS WE HONOR CESAR CHAVEZ
WE RECOGNIZE HIS LONGSTANDING
TUITION AT THE LEADERSHIP.
OF PARTNERSHIP AND COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO STRENGTHEN.
THE COALITION TO FIGHT AGAINST
ALL OPPRESSED WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO CENTER
HUESO.
THANK YOU OF MATTER OF US.
MISTER PRESIDENT -- YOU KNOW
NEXT MONTH APRIL TWENTY THIRD
WILL MARK THE TWENTY SIX YEAR.
SINCE SYSTEM CHAVEZ PASSING.
AND WE HAVE HERE PEOPLE HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE IN IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND AND IN MY
COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO.
ALSO THAT HAVE THAT WORK
DIRECTLY WITH HIM PEOPLE THAT
ARE STILL.
IN POWER TO TO HELP THEIR
COMMUNITY.
A LEGAL WE HAVE THE THE SEARCH
OF A SERVICE CLUBS.
THAT ARE WORKING WITH ALL
STUDENTS IN IN SCHOOLS IN SAN
DIEGO TO TO TEACH KIDS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF CIVIC CTIVISM
OF INVOLVEMENT.
OF OF LEADERSHIP.
CAN AND PROVIDING A VOICE -- IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS IS A A LEGACY THAT
STILL EXISTS TODAY FROM A PERSON
THAT HAD THE COURAGE. TO RISE
AND CHALLENGE A SYSTEM
[inaudible]
THAT VIEW.
PRIOR TO HIM [inaudible]
WERE.
BRAVE ENOUGH TO CHALLENGE.
SOMEBODY THAT ROSE UP IN A TIME
[inaudible]
WHEN?
A VERY LARGE POPULATION OUR
STATE HAD NO VOICE.
AT NO NO RESOURCES WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU LOOK AT ORGANIZATIONS A THE
FARM WORKERS -- THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS IS STILL AN ORGANIZATION.
THE NEED SUPPORT.
A NEW ORGANIZATION THAT IS STILL
FACING ENORMOUS OBSTACLES AN
ORGANIZATION THE STILL.
HAS MUCH TO SEE IN TERMS OF POP
PUBLIC POLICY TO HELP.
THE PEOPLE THEY REPRESENT.
AND TO THINK THAT A PERSON.
COMING FROM A POSITION OF OF
SUCH FEW RESOURCES REPRESENTING
THE POOREST OF THE POOR IN OUR
STATE.
COULD RISE TO THE NATIONAL
DEBATE.
AND INSPIRE MANY MORE PEOPLE
THAT ROSE AFTER HIM AND RESULT
OF HIS ACTIVISM HE INSPIRED MANY
PEOPLE AT THAT TIME.
HE WAS PART OF A OF A OF AN
AWAKENING IN THE SIXTIES.
THAT -- THAT.
EMPOWERED THE DISENFRANCHISED
AND EMPOWER COMMUNITIES AND LET
THE IN ALL OF THE LIKE.
YOU KNOW WHAT OF MARTIN LUTHER
KING DID FOR THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY SUCH SUCH
OBVIOUS TO FOR THE LATINO
COMMUNITY.
AND IT HAD AN IMPACT IN MY OWN
PERSONAL LIFE.
AND I SAW PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY
BE INSPIRED BY SOMEBODY WILLING
TO STAND UP.
AND CHALLENGE THE SYSTEM AND
THEY THEMSELVES -- STAND UP.
IS START FIGHTING -- AND
CREATING -- NONPROFITS LIKE IN
SAN DIEGO WITH A CREATED MAC
PROJECT THE CHICANO FEDERATION.
A GROUP OF OF RESIDENTS IN
BOREAL LOGAN TOOK OVER AS A
STATE OWNED PROPERTY IN CREATING
WHAT IS NOW.
A NATIONAL UP.
STORE EXCITE -- THE BAR YOU
LOGAN COMMUNITY PARK THAT YOU
COULD KNOWN AS CHICANO PARK.
ALL THIS ACTIVISM GAVE ROSE A
GAVE RISE -- DO WHAT WAS.
WAS A RESULT OF I MEAN A RESULT
OF ONE PERSON STANDING UP SAYING
I'M GONNA FIGHT. FOR FOR THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
WHO WHO ARE NOT?
IN THE IN IN THE BEST OF
CIRCUMSTANCES ECONOMICALLY.
AND AND YOU KNOW.
IN TERMS OF THEIR THEIR THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE.
SO YOU KNOW THIS IS A A PROUD
MOMENT FOR FOR PEOPLE THE LATINO
COMMUNITY THAT WERE INSPIRED TO
COMMUNITY SERVICE BY BY ONE
FIGURE.
AND AND I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S APPROPRIATE THE
CALIFORNIA HAVE -- A FESTIVE DAY
A DAY OF REMEMBRANCE A DAY OF
CELEBRATION FOR FOR SUCH CHAVEZ
BECAUSE IT HE STARTED THIS
MOVEMENT THIS NATIONWIDE
MOVEMENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK CALIFORNIA'S A
DIFFERENT STATE.
BECAUSE THIS WAS ONE PERSON
START UP.
ANY POWER IN ENTIRE.
AN ENTIRE CONSTITUENCY AT AN
ENTIRE GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THAT WHAT TO THAT POINT.
WERE WERE DISENFRANCHISED NOT
CYNICALLY ACTIVATED AND NOW WE
CALIFORNIA HAD BECOME A
POWERHOUSE THAT HAVE AFFECTED
OUR POLITICS.
FACTORED OTHER DISTRIBUTION OF
OF OF THE MEMBERS HERE THE THE
THE DIVERSITY.
OF MEMBERS HERE IT HAS TAKEN
INDIVIDUALS -- LIKE SISTER
CHAVEZ TO STAND UP.
AND AND BE HEARD AND AND MAKE AN
IMPACT. TO TO EMPOWER PEOPLE
LIKE ME TO WANNA.
RUN FOR GOVERNMENT -- AND
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN MAKE CHANGE
IN THIS COUNTRY AGAINST
FORMIDABLE ODDS THAT EXIST WORK
IN AGAINST THAT SO.
THIS IS A LIKE I MENTIONED A
PROUD MOMENT I RISE AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD.
AND URGE EVERYONE. TO VOTE FOR
IT -- IN A RESPECT PROCESO
CHAVEZ IN RESPECT FOR WHAT HE
STOOD FOR WHAT HE FOUGHT FOR BUT
ALSO.
IN THE ENORMOUS CONTRIBUTIONS HE
MADE AT MAKING OUR STATE A MORE
EQUITABLE PLACE TO LIVE FOR
EVERYONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO CENTER
ARCHULETA.
MISTER PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT SR.
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO STOOD UP.
BEFORE ALL OF US STOOD KNOWLEDGE
IS GREAT MAN.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT AS WE
HEARD HE IS A VETERAN.
BUT FOR THE YEARS THAT I'VE
SERVED REPRESENTED VETERANS
HERE'S ONE IS A VERY SPECIAL
VETERANS.
FEATURED AS WE ALL KNOW SERVE
UNITED STATES NAVY.
AT A TIME WHEN THE THE NAVY WHEN
HE JOINED THERE WAS SOME ISSUES.-WITH HISPANICS AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS THEY HAD TO DEAL WITH
ISSUES THAT MANY OF US TODAY
DON'T DEAL WITH ANY LONGER.
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE LIKE MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND CESAR CHAVEZ.
AND IN OUR COMMUNITY MY
COMMUNITY OF PEAK RIVERA.
WE HAVE 97% LATINOS.
AND I'VE BEEN INTO MANY MANY
HOMES AND I SEE THREE PICTURES.
JOHN F. KENNEDY MARTIN LUTHER
KING AS CESAR CHAVEZ.
AND THESE ARE THE THE MAN THAT --
WE ALL HAVE LEARNED TO LOVE AND
HONOR.
BUT SHE CHAVEZ AS A AS A VETERAN.
WHO SURE OF THIS GREAT COUNTRY
WITH HONOR ANDDIGNITY AND PRIDE
IN HIS UNIFORM?
AND AS WE HEARD TO COME HOME IS
STILL FIND ISSUES WHAT A SHAME.
AND AS I'VE MENTIONED ONCE
BEFORE WHEN I WAS STATIONED IN
NORTH CAROLINA I ACTUALLY SAW IT
FOR MYSELF.
BUT THE HERE THAT IT WAS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AT THAT TIME SHAMEFUL.
BUT I KNOW THE ONE THING THAT
TEACHER CHAVEZ IT BROUGHT US ALL
TOGETHER.
AS A NATION HAS A COMMUNITY AT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT THE LOVE OF OF THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO SERVE THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
IS AN EXAMPLE OF HIS SERVICE SO
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE VETERAN
THAT WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF
CESAR CHAVEZ WHO SERVED THIS
GREAT COUNTRY.
AND OUR NATION AND HE WILL NEVER
BE FORGOTTEN AND I THANK YOU SO
I'M IN SUPPORT OF US ARE TWENTY
FOUR NOT URGENT BY BOAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATE ARCHULETA
SENATOR BELL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF MY HOMETOWN SAN JOSE
HAS A VERY UNIQUE CONNECTION
WITH -- SAYS ARE CHAVEZ AND I
PERSONALLY HAVE A VERY UNIQUE
CONNECTION -- WITH HIM WE WE
CONSIDER OURSELVES -- HIM A PART
OF OUR COMMUNITY HE LIVED IN OUR
COMMUNITY IN SAN JOSE.
AND FOUNDED A ORGANIZATION
CALLED THE COMMUNITY SERVICE
ORGANIZATION.
IN THE SAN JOSE [inaudible]
OF THERE WAS IT WAS SIR LIKE A
VERSION OF A SOCIAL WELFARE --
ORGANIZATION IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
CALLED SOUTHSIDE WHERE THIS.
AND SAYS ARE CHARMERS.
COINED THE PHRASE SI SE PUEDE I
TO TURN AROUND PEOPLE IN SOUTH
SAFE WITH THIS.
AND THAT WAS A STE IT WAS A
NEIGHBORHOOD AT NO STREETS NO
PAVE ROADS IT WAS -- HOUSING
WITH -- WAS WAS HORRIBLE -- LOT
OF PEOPLE.
IT WAS THE FIRST PLACE THEY CAME
TO SAN JOSE -- AND AT THE TIME --
HE RAN THIS ORGANIZATION MY
MOTHER ACTUALLY VOLUNTEERED FOR
THE ORGANIZATION.
SUNDAYS AFTER CHURCH SHE TOOK
OUR BIG STATION WAGON BECAUSE WE
HAD TEN KIDS SHE HAD A NINE
PASSENGER STATION WAGON.
PULLED DOWN ALL THE SEATS.
DROVE OVER THERE AND PICKED UP
GROCERIES BAGS.
AND DELIVERED -- TO HOMES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND SHE HAD THIS YOUNG GUY JIM
BELL SON.
NAVIGATE -- WHERE THE GROCERY
BAGS WERE TO BE DELIVER THAT WAS
MY JOB?
SO I ONLY FOUND OUT LATER THAT
SAYS OUR WAS THE ONE THAT HELPED
LOW THE GROCERY BAGS IN MY
MOTHER'S CAR.
AND THIS IS LIKE ABOUT WHEN I
WAS TWELVE OKAY -- I PAY MY WAY
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL IN --
COLLEGE JOB WORKING.
IN THE FIELDS FOR TEN YEARS SO
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH -- THE
AGRICULTURAL -- DIFFICULTIES IN
TERMS OF FARM LABOR LAWS AND IN
FACT IN -- NINETEEN SIXTY SIX I
WAS WORKING IN A TOMATO FIELD
AND SNORE SAN JOSE.
AND THESE GUYS CAME WITH THIS --
RED FLAG WITH THE BLACK EAGLE.
AND I WAS JUST A TEENAGER I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS WAS I
WALKED OVER A NEW ONE OF THEM I
CAME OVER -- AND I SAID HEY MIKE.
BECAUSE I KNEW THE GUY MIKE
JOHNSON IS FROM.
SIR MINING'S DISTRICT KNOWS
MIGHT -- I SAID WHAT'S GOING ON
WHAT IS THIS HE SAID WHAT WE'RE
BOYCOTTING THIS FIELD -- BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT SUPPORTING THE
UNION I SAID OKAY WOULD YOU WANT
TO DO.
HE SAYS WHY DON'T YOU GUYS GO
FIND ANOTHER PLACE TO PICK
TOMATOES.
SO WE DID WE FOUND ANOTHER PLACE
TO PICK TOMATOES SO I ACTUALLY
WALKED OFF THE FIELD.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX RECESS OR
CHAVEZ IN THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BILL.
ORGANIZING COMMITTEE AT THE TIME
IT WAS CALLED RIGHT -- AND LATER
IT WAS -- AS I WORKED MY WAY
THROUGH COLLEGE I WORKED WITH
THIS SHORT HOLE.
AND I HOLD VEGETABLES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FROM OUR BEEN TO
MODESTO WE WOULD MY BROTHER AND
I WOULD GO UP AND DOWN THE
VALLEY -- EVERY SUMMER.
LATER SENATOR CHAVEZ OUTLAWED
THE SHORE HOLE.
THE SHORE HOLE WAS A BACK
BREAKING DEVICE.
THAT -- BECAUSE A LOT OF PAIN
INJURY TO PEOPLE SO I ACTUALLY --
WORK WITH MY BROTHER.
HOLDING OF FLOWERS AND
VEGETABLES WITH THE SHORT H
AND LASTLY I SAY THIS -- MANY
MARCHERS -- I REMEMBER SEEING.
EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP IN THE RED HOTS WHEN I
THINK A RED HAT'S I REMEMBER THE
MARCH FROM WATCHING BUILDS A
SALINAS.
AND THE PEOPLE COMING UP WE WERE
COMING FROM WHAT'S A BILL TO
SALINAS ON THE LETTUCE BOYCOTT.
AND THE PEOPLE COMING FROM KING
CITY. TO SALINAS MARCHING UP
FROM KING CITY.
AND WE KIND OF MERGED TOGETHER
AT A RALLY POINT AND ALL THOSE
PEOPLE HAD RED HAT'S.
SO WHEN I THINK OF RED HATS I
THINK OF THE BUT ANSEL LETTUCE
WORKERS.
WALKING UP FROM TING CITY WITH
RED HAT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
AND LE YEAH I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT -- THERE'S A LOT OF
MEMORIES WITH HIM -- THE LAST
THING I GUESS SAY IS ONE TIME I
WENT TO THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING HE STARTED
THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PROGRAM.
THAT IS NOW.
TRAINED OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA FOR JOBS HE
STARTED IN HIS GARAGE.
IN EAST SAN JOSE.
SO IF YOU EVER HEAR THE CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT TRAINING THAT'S
THAT WAS STARTED IN SAYS OUR
TRAVIS IS GARAGE AND HE SAN JOSE.
AND I REMEMBER GOING TO ONE OF
THEIR EVENTS IN SAN JOSE.
AND THEY SAID OKAY COUNCILMAN
YOU CAN COME UP AND SPEAK NOW.
AND I WALKED UP ON THE STAGE I
HEARD THIS LARGE ROLL YOUR FROM
THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THERE
WERE THERE ARE CELEBRATING.
I THINK THE TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY -- OF THE GROUP AND
I THOUGHT.
WHAT'S GOING ON THAT'S NOT FOR
ME.
AND I TURNED AROUND AND SAYS ARE
WAS STANDING RIGHT BEHIND ME.
SO -- I REMEMBER MEETING HIM
MANY TIMES.
HE WAS ALWAYS JUST THIS
WONDERFUL HUMBLE HUMBLE PERSON.
AND THAT'S A TRUE STATEMENT IT
JUST MADE HIM SO MANY TIMES HE
WAS ALWAYS A VERY HUMBLE AND
VERY INSPIRATIONAL PER PER
PERSON.
THAT -- A LOT OF US KNOW
PERSONALLY.
AND WEEK WE THINK THAT THIS IS --
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE RESOLUTION
FOR CENTER.
AND WE'RE SO PROUD THAT WE HAVE
THE PLAZA IN SAN JOSE WHERE THE
CAPITAL FIRST WAS.
STATE CAPITOL NAMED AFTER SAYS
ARE CHAVEZ IN SAN JOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- CENTER BELL SEEING
NO OTHER MIKE SUB -- SENATOR
ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
NOT ONLY TODAY AND ASSESSORS
NAME BUT IN EVERYTHING THAT HE
STOOD FOR IN ALL OF OUR FUTURE
LEGISLATION AND VOTES.
THE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE.
CALL.
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO HI -- TADA
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M RAIL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I AMBERG.
BOB I COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK HI HI SENATOR DRAWS A
MOVES A CALL.
NOW WILL PROCEED TO FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN AND THAT WOULD BE
SENATOR CHIANG S. C. R.. TWENTY
FIVE MR. SIX FIFTEEN SARDANA
READERS ON MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR CHIANG
RELATIVE TO WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
STEM WEEK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AS WE CELEBRATE WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH.
I AM HONORED TO BRING U. S. C.
R. FIFTEEN A RESOLUTION TO
COMMEMORATE APRIL SEVENTH
THROUGH THIRTEEN AS WOMEN AND
GIRLS IN STEM WEEK.
WE'RE ALL WHAT WELL WHERE THAT
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
AND MATHEMATICS ARE CRUZ FILLED
THE MAN CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
THE REST OF THE NATION.
AS LEGISLATORS WE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE TODAY'S YOUTH TO
PARTICIPATE IN STEM FIELDS FOR
TOMORROW'S FUTURE.
GEN CAREERS CONTINUE TO BE ON
THE RISE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE SOME OF THE HIGHEST
PAYING POSITIONS IN ANY FIELD.
WELL WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS WOMEN
CONTINUE TO BE UNDERREPRESENTED
IN STEM FIELDS.
WOMEN MAKE UP NEARLY ONE HALF OF
THE WORKING POPULATION BUT THE
ONLY REPRESENT 26% OF THE STEM
FORCE.
AS YOU ALL KNOW WE CANNOT
CONTROL THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WE ARE BORN INTO.
WHAT WE CAN CONTROL IS THE
ABILITY TO PROMOTE AND INSPIRE
ONE ANOTHER? TO BE BETTER. TO GO
FARTHER THAN OUR PARENTS DID TO
REACH NEW HEIGHTS IN ACADEMIA.
TO MAKE WHAT ONCE SEEMED
IMPOSSIBLE POSSIBLE.
STUDIES SHOW THAT STEM INTEREST
IN STEM PEAKS AT EARLY AGES FOR
GIRLS AND THEN.
THE CLIENTS THROUGHOUT THE
PRIMARY AND SECONDARY EDUCATION.
WE CAN DO BETTER FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
WE NEED TO LET GIRLS KNOW ABOUT
THE MANY WOMEN ROLE MODELS OUT
THERE.
DOCTOR TO DATA EISLER THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO EARN A
PHD IN ASTROPHYSICS.
FACEBOOK CEO -- SHERYL SANDBERG
AND DOCTOR ALLEN'S A SO FINE
THREE SCIENTISTS AT NASA.
THEY CONTINUE TO BE A SOURCE OF
INSPIRATION FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS.
WHEN WE HIGHLIGHT AND CELEBRATE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED AMAZING GOALS
NGUYEN EVERYBODY CREATE
INSPIRATION WITHIN OURSELVES TO
DO THE SAME?
S. C. R. FIFTEEN CREATES A
PLATFORM TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT BY SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STANLEY.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG
[inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS DISCUSSIONS THING NINE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RIVER CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORCHES.
BY BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD.
BY THE RISE OF BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WITH SO.
HI -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI MORRELL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBER [inaudible]
HI KATHY [inaudible]
HI WIENER.
HI WILK HI HI AND AUTHOR MOVES
TO CALL.
NOW WE MOVE TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
CENTER LABOR ARE YOU PREPARED I
AM PREPARED.
SO -- MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FOR
BY SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE TO
TITLE.
TEN THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE WRIST
JOINT RESOLUTION FOR WHICH
ADDRESSES RECENT CHANGES TO THE
FEDERAL TITLE TEN REGULATIONS
AND SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S STANDS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE TITLE TEN IS A FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAM DEDICATED TO
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES.
THESE IMPORTANT SERVICES INCLUDE
COPPERS CONTRACEPTIVE CARE
PREGNANCY TESTING DIAGNOSING AND
TREATING SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS.
INFERTILITY SERVICES AND
PREGNANCY OPTION COUNSELING.
CLEARLY THESE ARE ALL CRITICAL
SERVICES.
EARLIER THIS MONTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RELEASED NEW FUNDING
REGULATIONS FOR TITLE.
TEN THESE REGULATIONS THE NIGHT
WOMEN INFORMATION ABOUT HEALTH
CARE OPTIONS DISRUPT THE
PROVIDER PATIENT RELATIONSHIP
ENDED HER CALIFORNIANS FROM
ACCESSING CARE.
BY TYING FEDERAL FUNDING TO
THESE RELATE REGULATIONS MANY
HEALTH CARE ORGANIZATIONS AND
QUALIFIED FAMILY PLANNING
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE
FORCED TO CHOOSE.
BETWEEN A CRITICAL FUNDING
SOURCE AND ACCEPTING REGULATIONS
THAT WILL REDUCE ACCESS TO
QUALITY TIME SENSITIVE CARE FOR
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS.
ACCORDING TO ESSENTIAL ACCESS
HEALTH APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE SERVED BY TITLE
TEN PROGRAMS ACCOUNTING 425% OF
TOTAL TEN TEN PATIENTS
NATIONWIDE.
THIS MEANS THAT THE IMPACTS OF
THESE NEW TITLE TEN REGULATIONS
WILL BE FELT MOST INTENSELY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND CALIFORNIA WOMEN OF FAMILIES
WILL BE THE ONES TO BEAR THE
BRUNT OF THESE ACTIONS.
THE REGULATIONS WOULD ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND REVERSE
THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE IN
REDUCING.
UNINTENDED PREGNANCY RATES IN
OUR STATE.
ESTE ARE FOR RGIS UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO RESEND THESE
REGULATIONS AND SENDS A CLEAR
MESSAGE THE CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORTS ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
WHO NEED THIS IMPORTANT CARE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO OTHER MIKE'S UP --
OVER HERE TO THE RIGHT I'M SORRY.
CENTER MORE LIKE PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
TOMORROW MARCH TWENTY NINTH --
THEY'LL BE AN INTERESTING --
MOVIE PREPARE PREMIERING IN THAT
IN THE NATION CALLED.
RUSHES MEANS IT'S BASED ON THE
BOOK OF WRITTEN BY ABBIE JOHNSON
AND IT'S TITLED UNPLANNED AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE.
MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF THEY CAN
FIND SOME TIME OVER THE HOLIDAY
WEEKEND TO SEE THE MOVIE THANK
YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU CENTER MORE LOOK.
SEEING OTHER MIKE SET CENTER
LABOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
BY DORADO BY GALGIANI
[inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
HI -- TOTAL.
BY JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
HI MORE LUCK.
NO MORALE NO.
NIELSEN.
NO PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN BY STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BYE BYE CATHY.
BYE WINNER.
HI WILK NO NO.
AND THE AUTHOR MOVES THE CALL
NOW WE PROCEED TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN SENATOR BELL ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP SB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT OR WITH.
US MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR BILL AN ACT RULING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
YEAH BOB GOOD MORNING MEMBERS --
WE RISE 2% -- SP -- ONE TWENTY
EIGHT AFTER THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES SO WE
WORK TO CREATE THE REFINED SOME
TOOLS. FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
TO FINANCE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS THE ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT LAW BEGAN WITH MY BILL
SB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT IN -- TWENTY
FOURTEEN R. E. I. F. THESE
PROVIDED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
THE WAY FINANCE OF NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
WITH TAX INCREMENT FINANCING.
THIS IS A USEFUL TOOL BUT IS
YOUR UNDERUTILIZED.
WE HAVE -- LOOKED INTO SOME OF
THE BARRIERS TO USING THESE
TOOLS -- AND EF ID'S REQUIRE A
55% VOTE TO APPROVE BONDS.
THE SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH --
THEY DID A REPORT ON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FINANCING AND
IDENTIFIED THIS IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR BARRIERS -- FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
THE ELECTION REQUIREMENT ADDS AN
ELEMENT OF UNCERTAINTY RESTRICTS
THE ABILITY OF THE IRAQIS MAKING
LONG TERM COMMITMENTS.
OF THE LAW -- YES BE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT REPLACES THE ELECTION.
WITH PROTESTS PROCESS AND
ENHANCES IT IN IS MODELED AFTER
SB -- NINE SIXTY ONE BY THE
CENTER FOR LOS ANGELES -- THE
NIFTY TO BILL WHICH PASSED THE
SENATE FLOOR LAST YEAR WITH
THIRTY EIGHT VOTES.
SO WE'RE MONITORING THE PROTEST --
THAT WE ENHANCE IN THIS BILL
AFTER THE LAW WE PASSED LAST
YEAR.
LIKE NIFTY AYE APPEASING
CREATORS COMMUNITY REINVEST
COMMUNITY REDEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENT.
PROGRAMS.
CHANGES THE TO THESE FINANCING
DISTRICTS ARE NOT SUBJECT. TO
THE CONSTITUTIONAL DEBT LIMIT
AND THE TWO THIRDS VOTING
REQUIREMENTS.
THE PROPERTY TAXES ALLOCATED TO
EACH OF THESE ARE NOT NEW TAXES.
THESE -- I OF THE FIFTIES CANNOT
AND DO NOT INCREASE TAXES ARE
TAX RATES.
THE E. I'VE THE LAW REQUIRES
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN THE
GOVERNANCE.
MANDATING THE BOARD OF OF THE
PUBLIC FINANCING AUTHORITY
INCLUDE PUBLIC MEMBERS.
SB A ONE TWENTY EIGHT ALSO
INCLUDES A ROBUST LANDOWNER
RESIDENT PROTESTS PROCESS.
CREATED BY OUR MEMBERS THAT WE
PRODUCE IN MARCH.
THE SP ONE TWENTY EIGHT PUBLIC
PROCESS.
OF MODELED AFTER -- NINE SIXTY
ONE REQUIRES A ROBUST THREE STEP
PROTESTS PROCESS -- THERE'S
GOING TO BE THREE HEARINGS.
THE HEARING COMMENT ON ALL
PUBLIC COMMENTS -- TO CONSIDER
THAT -- E. I. R. P.
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
REQUIRES THE PUBLIC FINANCING
AUTHORITY TERMINATE.
THE E. IFT INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN
IF THERE IS A MAJORITY PROTESTS.
REQUIRES AN ELECTION OF BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND 50%.
OF THE COMBINED NUMBER LANDERS
AND RESIDENTS IN THE AREA.
WHO ARE AT LEAST EIGHTEEN YEARS
OF AGE PROFILE PROTEST?
THE GOVERNOR TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS CLING TO BROWN AT
OPEN MEETING LAW PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT.
AND POLITICAL REFORM ACT ALL
APPLY.
TO THESE -- HIGHER TONIGHT VOTE
AND THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
A COLLEAGUES -- IT WOULD APPEAR
THAT HE AYE EMPTIES AND HANSON
PRINT INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS DO NOT REQUIRE A TWO
THIRDS.
VOTER APPROVAL THEREFORE SB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT IS MINISTERIAL.
AS THE 55% VOTER APPROVAL WAS
PROBABLY ORIGINALLY INCLUDED IN
THE ORIGINAL INCEPTION LANGUAGE.
BUT THE LACK OF VOTER
INVOLVEMENT.
OTHER THAN ELECTING THEIR CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS.
ADD TO HAVE -- IS ABOUT THE ONLY
DIRECT WAY THAT THEY CAN GET
INVOLVED IN APPROVING THE I'VE
D. I. F. D..
BONDS CONSEQUENTLY THE PERCEIVED
SAFEGUARD OF A 55% VOTER
APPROVAL.
WAS ACTUALLY ILLUSIONARY BUT I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL.
THE SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE FOR
FINDING ALTERNATIVES. TO ASSURE
STRONGER FIDUCIARY STANDARDS FOR
BOND ISSUANCE THROUGH HIS
PROTEST PROCESS BUT I THINK WE
SHOULD BE CAREFUL WHEN WE ADOPT
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW FOR THE
ISSUANCE OF BONDS.
THAT EXCLUDE THE VOTERS FROM
BEING INVOLVED BECAUSE OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION IS PRETTY CLEAR
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A TWO THIRDS
INVOLVEMENT FOR ANY DEBT.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU MISTER MURDOCH.
SEE NO FURTHER MIKE SAT --
CENTER BELL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SIR
WATER -- IN TERMS OF THE LOG
SPECIFICALLY THE BONDS -- FROM --
THE E. I. F. THESE ARE ONLY THE
DEBT OF THE I. E. I. OF DE NOT
CAESAR COUNTIES.
AND THE BONDS NOT CONSTITUTE
INDIAN DEAFNESS WITHIN THE
MEANING OF ANY CONSTITUTIONAL.
OR STATUTORY DEPTH LIMITATIONS
SO.
SO THAT'S WHY THE NORMAL
PROCESSES THESE DO NOT REQUIRE A
VOTE.
I REGION I VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
OUR BY CARRIER.
I CHANGED [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER.
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
BY WITH SOME BY OUR TITLE
[inaudible]
I JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
BY KATHY.
BY WINNER BY WILK NO NO.
AUTHOR MOVES THE CALL.
NOW WE MOVE TO FIVE ITEM.
TWENTY AND THAT WOULD BE SB TWO
TO THREE FROM SENATOR HILL.
ARE YOU PREPARED SIR I AM.
PRESS SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR HILL AND ACTUALLY PEOPLE
HEALTH.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
GOOD MORNING THIS BE TO TWENTY
THREE JO JO'S ACT.
WILL HELP STUDENTS WITH SEVERE
MEDICAL DISABILITIES ATTEND
SCHOOL.
THE ONLY MEDICATION THAT WORKS
FOR SOME OF THESE STUDENTS IS
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN TO COME ON CAMPUS TO
ADMINISTER MEDICAL CANNABIS TO
THEM IN NON SMOKING NON VAPING
FORMS.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS NEED TO
TAKE A DOSE OF MEDICINAL
CANNABIS AT REGULAR INTERVALS
WHICH OFTEN INCLUDES DURING
SCHOOL HOURS CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT ALLOW ANY FORM OF CANNABIS
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS.
THE STUDENTS MUST BE PICKED UP
BY THEIR PARENTS.
AND TAKEN OFF CAMPUS A THOUSAND
FEET TO FROM CAMPUS.
IN ORDER TO TAKE THEIR MEDICINE.
THIS IS VERY DISRUPTIVE TO THEIR
EDUCATION AND TO THEIR LEARNING.
SB.
TWO TWENTY THREE WILL ALLOW THE
GOVERNING BOARD OF A KEY TO
TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICT COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS. TO CHOOSE WHETHER TO
ADOPT THIS POLICY.
IT IS NOT A STATE MANDATE
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES THAT UP
IN CAN OPT OUT FOR ANY REASON
INCLUDING IF FEDERAL FUNDING IS
PUT AT RISK AS A RESULT OF THIS
POLICY.
SB TWO TWENTY THREE REQUIRES THE
STUDENT TO BE A QUALIFIED
MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENT.
WITH A DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION.
TYPICALLY THE MEDICINE IS
ADMINISTERED AS OIL CAPSULES
TEACHERS LIQUIDS OR TOPICAL
CREAMS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT A
PARENT MUST GIVE THE SCHOOL A
COPY OF THEIR CHILD'S MEDICAL
CANNABIS RECOMMENDATION TO KEEPON FILE.
SIGN IN WHEN THEY COME ON CAMPUS
TO ADMINISTER THE MEDICINE NOT
DISRUPT THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT INTAKE ALL CANNABIS
OFFICE SCHOOL GROUNDS.
AFTER ADMINISTRATION WASHINGTON
COLORADO FLORIDA MAINE AND NEW
JERSEY HAVE ALL PASSED
LEGISLATION ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
USE MEDICAL CANNABIS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES.
THIS BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL I WOULD
REMIND THE FLORIDA PLEASE HOLD
IT DOWN IF YOU HAVE A PRIVATE
CONVERSATION PLEASE TAKE IT OFF
THE FLOOR.
I SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU SIR I WON APPLY THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CERTAINLY
SHOULD NOT GET IN THE WAY OF THE
DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP --
THE REASON WHY WE HAVEN'T BETTER
UNDERSTOOD THE EFFICACY OF THE
MEDICAL BENEFITS OF CANNABIS IS
BECAUSE IT REMAINS A SCHEDULE
ONE DRUG WHICH MEANS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO RESEARCH IN THE
UNITED STATES. FOR THE
THERAPEUTIC UTILIZATION OF
CANNABIS SINISTER RIVETED.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY
IS HYPOCRITICAL.
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY HAVE CAN
AVOID THAT ARE LEGALLY ALLOWED
THROUGH THE FDA BUT YET THE D.
A. STILL SAY IT STILL SAYS THAT
THERE'S NO MEDICAL VALUE FOR
THEM SO HOPEFULLY THE AND WE
PASSED A RESOLUTION THAT I
AUTHORED LAST YEAR.
THAT -- URGE THE FEDERAL
SCHEDULE.
ONE BECAUSE IF YOU SEE THE
RESEARCH THAT IS DONE IN
COUNTRIES LIKE ISRAEL YOU'LL SEE
THAT THE EFFICACY. FOR THINGS
SUCH AS CHILDHOOD SEIZURE
DISORDERS -- THE CBD OILS THAT --
DRAMATICALLY HAVE STOPPER
TRADITIONAL MEDICATIONS HAVE NOT
AND THE OTHER UTILIZATION THIS --
OF OF CANNABIS THAT HAVE COME TO
LIGHT SO I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- I
BELIEVE THAT CANNABIS SHOULD BE
NO DIFFERENT THAN THE OTHER
PRESCRIBE MEDICATION AND
ADMINISTERED ULTIMATELY BY A
SCHOOL NURSE FOR THE PERMISSION
OF THE PARENT UNDERSTANDING
THERE'S A PRESCRIPTION FOR THAT
MEDICATION BECAUSE OF A GREAT
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR AND I URGE
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE SEEING NO
OTHER MIKE'S UP CENTER HILL YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM TO MACULA FOR
HIS COMMENTS AND REALLY THE THE
THOUGHTFULNESS OF OF THE ISSUE.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
IS PREVENTED PREVENTING CHILDREN
FROM GETTING AN EDUCATION
GETTING THE OPPORTUNITY HAVING
THAT OPPORTUNITY. TO GET AN
EDUCATION AT SCHOOL WHEN THEIR
PARENTS AND IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE JOE JOE.
HAS TO GO OFF CAMPUS IN A
WHEELCHAIR A THOUSAND FEET.
EVERY DAY WHICH TAKES A LOT OF
TIME AND A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
AWAY FROM THE EDUCATION.
THAT HE SO MUCH DESERVED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN
[inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
BY FOR JUST.
NOPE BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHANGE [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
BY DORADO.
BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
HI MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER AYE STERN.
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BUY A COPY BYWINNER.
HI WILK HI HI SENATOR HILL MOVES
THE CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE AND THAT WOULD BE
S. R. S. C. R. TWENTY SIX CENTER
JACKSON ARE YOU PREPARED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR JACKSON
RELATIVE TO EQUAL PAY DAY.
CENTER JACKSON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES.
WE STARTED OFF THIS MORNING
TALKING ABOUT EQUALITY
[inaudible]
AND ACKNOWLEDGING THE
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS BY SAYS
ARE CHAVEZ.
TO PROVIDE THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
FARMWORKERS IN OUR STATE.
TODAY I BRING FORWARD S. C. R.
TWENTY SIX WHICH IS ANOTHER
EFFORT TO ACHIEVE EQUALITY IN
OUR STATE NATION.
RECOGNIZING EQUAL PAY DAY.
WHICH IS ON TUESDAY OF THE
COMING WEEK.
AS MANY OF YOU I WOULD SUBMIT
PROBABLY MOST IF NOT ALL OF YOU
KNOW BECAUSE YOU HAVE SPOUSES OR
DAUGHTERS OR MOTHERS.
WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE WORK FORCE
AND WHO HAVE BY VIRTUE OF GENDER?
BEEN DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN
PAY IN OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
ABILITY TO ADVANCE TO BE HIRED
TO BE PROMOTED OR HAVE BEEN
HARASSED SO THAT YOU HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO COMPLETE THE WORK.
IN THE KIND OF WAY THAT YOU AS
SOMEONE SEEKING EXCELLENCE AND
QUALITY IN THE WORK WOULD
WARRANT AND SO.
WE KNOW THAT FOR SO MANY.
WHO HAVE TO INTIMATELY THROUGH
LIFE EXPERIENCE IN THOSE WOMEN
HERE ON THE FLOOR I WOULD SUBMIT
WE HAVE ALL?
AT SOME POINT EXPERIENCE THAT
LEVEL OF INEQUALITY.
WE COME BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE EQUAL PAY DAY.
ADD TO RECOGNIZE CERTAIN FACTS
THAT CONTINUE TO EXIST.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND IN OUR
NATION IT IS ESTIMATED.
THEIR WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA OR
PAID ABOUT EIGHTY EIGHT CENTS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR A MAN MAKES.
WHICH AMOUNTS TO AN AVERAGE
ANNUAL WAGE GAP OF ABOUT SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THAT GAP HOWEVER IS WORSE
SIGNIFICANTLY WORSE FOR WOMEN OF
COLOR.
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN.
MAKE ON AVERAGE SIXTY ONE CENTS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR A WHITE MAN WAY
MAKES AND LATINOS IN CALIFORNIA.
HAVE THE DUBIOUS DISTINCTION OF
HAVING THE WORST.
WAGE GAP IN THE NATION.
LATINOS ARE PAID APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY THREE CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR PAID TO A WHITE NON
LATINO.
MALE.
THIS ISN'T JUST A PROBLEM THAT
AFFECTS WOMEN AS I MENTIONED
FAMILIES.
OUR IS SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
THIS BECAUSE WOMEN ARE IN THE
WORKFORCE TODAY IN GREATER
NUMBERS THAN EVER BEFORE AND ARE
IN THE WORKFORCE BECAUSE THEIR
INCOME IS NECESSARY FOR FAMILIES
TO MAKE.
ENDS MEET THAT MONEY STAYS IN
OUR COMMUNITY THAT MONEY
PURCHASES THE GOODS IN THE
SERVICES IN THIS NECESSITIES OF
LIFE.
THAT FAMILIES NEED.
AND CONTRARY TO WHAT SOME
BELIEVE THIS IS NOT A GAP THAT
CAN BE EXPLAINED AWAY SIMPLY BY
WOMEN'S LIFE CHOICES.
IT'S A GAP THAT EXISTS
REGARDLESS OF THE INDUSTRY WOMAN
WORKS IN.
WHETHER IT'S NURSING OR
MANUFACTURING IT'S A GAP THAT
EXISTS REGARDLESS OF A WOMAN.
TO OUR EDUCATIONAL LEVEL.
WOMEN WITH MASTER'S DEGREES ARE
STILL PAID LESS THAN MEN WITH
THE SAME DEGREE.
WOMEN WITH DOCTORAL DEGREES HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO BE PAID LESS THAN
MEN WITH MASTER'S DEGREES.
THIS MEASURE STR TWENTY SIX
KNOWLEDGES THAT APRIL SECOND.
TWENTY NINETEEN IS EQUAL PAY DAY
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS THE
DAY OF THE YEAR WHEN THE WAGES
PAID TO AMERICAN WOMEN.
CATCH UP TO THE WAGES PAID TO
MEN FOR THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
IN OTHER WORDS WE PUT IN A HARD
THREE EXTRA MONTHS BEFORE WE
MAKE WHAT A MAN HAS BEEN PAID
FOR THE PRIOR YEAR.
MORE THAN 60%.
OF WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA ARE
EMPLOYED.
AND NEARLY FOUR IN TEN MOTHERS
ARE THE PRIMARY BREADWINNER IN
THEIR HOUSEHOLDS. TWO THIRDS OF
MOTHERS ARE PRIMARY OR
SIGNIFICANT EARNERS MAKING PAY
EQUITY CRITICAL THE FAMILIES
ECONOMIC SECURITY.
I AM VERY PROUD THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO PASS.
IN THIS LEGISLATURE BACK IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHAT WAS THEN THE
STRONGEST EQUAL PAY BILL IN THE
COUNTRY.
THERE ARE NOW FORTY ONE OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE USE THAT EQUAL
PAY BILL AS A MODEL.
IT WAS PASSED WITH ALMOST
UNIVERSAL BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT
THERE IS MUCH WORK YET TO BE
DONE.
BECAUSE A LIFETIME OF LOWER PAY
MEANS WOMEN HAVE LESS INCOME. TO
SAVE FOR RETIREMENT AND LESS
INCOME COUNTED INTO SOCIAL
SECURITY OR PENSION BENEFITS.
PLEASE JOIN ME COLLEAGUES IN
SUPPORTING EQUAL PAY FOR WOMEN
ARE EQUAL PAY DAY AND A REMINDER
THAT THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO
BE DONE WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S.
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT -- TO APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA BARBARA FOR HER-CHAMPIONING -- EQUAL PAY.
FOR WOMEN -- GENDER -- ANY TYPE
OF DISCRIMINATION -- SHE'S BEEN
A CHAMPION AND I APPRECIATE HER
EFFORTS.
I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT --
LAST WEEK -- I HAVE A NEW
GRANDDAUGHTER NAME IS COREY
GENEVIEVE STONE.
I AM VERY -- EXCITED THAT MY MY
DAUGHTER BRITNEY.
IS EXPECTING TWIN GIRLS.
IN EARLY MAY.
SO THAT'S GOING TO GIVE ME --
FOUR GRANDDAUGHTERS.
I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
BUT I ALSO THINK CONCERN FOR
THEM BECAUSE I WANT THEM.
THEY HAVE A BETTER LIFE THAN
MYSELF.
AND I WANT TO ENSURE
[inaudible]
THAT.
WHEN THEY GET JOBS?
THAT THE JOB IS GOING TO BE
COMMENSURATE WITH [inaudible]
A MALE.
AND THAT THE PAY THAT THEY GET
WILL BE OBJECTIVE BASED ON THE
QUALIFICATIONS THAT THEY BRING
IN COMPARISON AND CONTRAST.
TO A MALE WHEN THEY APPLY FOR
THOSE JOBS.
BUT MY FRIENDS IF WE'RE GOING TO
BE REALISTIC ABOUT THIS WE CAN
ENACT LAWS.
WE HAVE TO SET AN EXAMPLE.
AND BY THAT I MEAN WE NEED TO
TAKE OUR A MAGNIFYING GLASS. TWO
OR THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
PLUS EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE.
GENDER EQUITY.
IN PAY.
IN OUR OWN STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE'RE
NOT THERE YET.
WE HAVE A WAYS TO GO.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IF SHE'S SO
INCLINED. TO ENSURE.
THAT PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
STAND.
FOR EQUAL PAY IRRESPECTIVE OF
THEIR GENDER IRRESPECTIVE OF
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
IRRESPECTIVE STE ON YOUR
QUALIFICATIONS AND YOUR
EDUCATION -- AND YOUR ABILITY TO
DO THE JOB.
EVERYONE SHOULD BE PAID FAIRLY.
AND EQUALLY AND WE NEED START
RIGHT WITHIN OUR OWN STATE
INSTITUTION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE AUTHOR
LOOK FOR TO SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER STORE FOR THOSE
COMMENTS SAYING CONGRATULATIONS
ON THE TO COMING GRANDDAUGHTERS
SEEING NO OTHER MIKE STEPS --
CENTER JACKSON PLEASE CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TIME
GOT A BOTTLE THAT STATEMENT BY
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM TO MACULA --
IT IS A IT ABOUT TIME THAT WE
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE AS A NON
PARTISAN ISSUE.
IT IS ONE THAT IS GOING -- TO
DEFINITELY CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE STATE AGAIN WE ARE THE
STATE THAT INVENTS THE FUTURE
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY
WHEN PEOPLE ARE PAID ON THE
BASIS OF THE QUALITY OF THEIR
WORK IN THE CONTENT OF THEIR
CHARACTER REGARDLESS OF GENDER
RACE CREED.
ETHNICITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION WE
HAVE STARTED THAT BATTLE.
JOINED AS WE TRY TO SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED WITHOUT AYE YOUR DRIVE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
BY BILL.
HI FOR JUST [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
WITH SO BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MOORLACH [inaudible]
BY RAIL [inaudible]
BY NIELSEN.
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
HI STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BYE BYE COUNTY.
BYE WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
WILK HI HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
ICE THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN S. C. R. THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR
ALLEN ARE YOU PREPARED.
YES THANK YOU MISS PRESENT
MEMBERS.
YES SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION DAYS.
MEMBERS AND A SENATOR ALLEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SENATOR AND AND THIS IS
SOMETHING IT'S NEAR AND DEAR TO
YOUR HEART I KNOW -- BECAUSE WE
SERVE TOGETHER THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON AEROSPACE AND
DEFENSE.
AND THIS BILL -- THIS THIS
RESOLUTION HAS TO DO WITH WITH
OUR A SERVICE ON THAT COMMITTEE
AND IT BASICALLY CELEBRATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OF FOLKS MAY KNOW AND
IN SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE SEEN --
FIRST MAN A WONDERFUL FILM ABOUT
THE LANDING OF THE APOLLO.
ELEVEN THIS YEAR IS THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF OF APOLLO.
ELEVEN I WAS THE FIRST MANNED
MISSION TO LAND ON THE MOON AND
THE FIRST TIME HUMANS EXPLORED A
PLANET OUTSIDE OF OUR OWN.
HI FOLKS MAY KNOW THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT JUST YESTERDAY TALKED
ABOUT WANTING TO RETURN AN
AMERICAN TO THE MOON.
I WAS VERY INTERESTING SO WHEN
WHEN NEIL ARMSTRONG TOOK ONE
SMALL STEP.
ON THE EARTH'S MOON HUMANITY
LEFT FORWARD INTO YOUR OF SPACE
EXPLORATION THAT CONTINUES TO
INSPIRE OUR COLLECTIVE
IMAGINATION CHALLENGE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE WE FIT
INTO THE UNIVERSE AND ALSO
INSPIRE YOUNG PEOPLE. TO STUDY
IN ENGAGE IN SCIENCE -- I'M
PROUD THAT IN MY DISTRICT --
THAT'S OFTEN KNOWN AS THE BRAIN
TRUST OF THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE IT'S HOME OF THE LA
AIRFORCE BASE IN EL SEGUNDO
WHICH IS THE ONLY ACTIVE.
DUTY MILITARY BASE IN THE LA
AREA BUT IT FOCUSES ON ON OUR
INDIE IT'S IT'S GOT A SPACE AND
MISSILE SYSTEMS CENTER THAT
DEVELOPS DEPLOYS AND SUSTAINS
OUR NAY OUR NATION'S MILITARY
SPACE SYSTEMS INCLUDING GPS
SATELLITE COMMUNICATIONS DEFENSE
METEOROLOGICAL SATELLITES IN.
A SPACE BASED INFRARED CAMERAS
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT -- THAT
FOLKS FROM ALL OVER THE STATE
HAVE IMPORTANT I AEROSPACE -- IT
INSTITUTIONS IN THEIR IN THEIR
DISTRICTS AS WELL INCLUDING
YOURS MISTER PRESIDENT.
I NAY DIVISIONS ORIGINALLY FROM
AEROSPACE RESEARCH INCLUDE
WEATHER FORECASTING WIRLESS AND
LONG DISTANCE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPUTER JOYSTICKS WATER FILTERS
THE ARTIFICIAL HEART THE
ELECTRIC CAR EVEN BARCODES.
IN STUDIES ESTIMATE THAT THE IRA
SPACE INDUSTRIES REVENUES IN
CALIFORNIA -- PROXIMALLY SIXTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND
FOLKS THAT IS ROUGHLY EQUIVALENT
TO OUR AGRICULTURE AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRIES COMBINE
TO ICONIC INDUSTRIES. FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
REMAINS THE UNDISPUTED WORLD
WIDE AT THE CENTER OF COMMERCIAL
ACADEMIC IN GOVERNMENT RELATED
AEROSPACE ACTIVITY AND I ASKED
YOU JOIN ME.
IN SUPPORTING US YOU ARE THIRTY
FOUR GRADUALLY THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF AEROSPACE FOR A JOB WELL DONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN.
SEEING NO OTHER MY MIKE'S UP
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL.
I WERE JUST [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
I WITH SO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY NUMBER.
I LIKE CASKEY BY WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
BY HI.
YEAH THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS.
THEY'RE ALSO.
BY [inaudible]
THE GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
OKAY ICE THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. ONE
MOMENT MEMBERS
.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WERE IN BEGIN
TO LET THE CALLS.
FIRST ITEM WILL BE FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT SR TWENTY SIX
SENATOR BRCHERS.
MISTER SECRETARY.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
PORTANTINO HI.
ICE.
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW WE'LL TURN TO FILE ITEM
TWELVE SR TWENTY FOUR DORADO
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI.
HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW WE MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN S. C. R. FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR CHIANG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS.
GROVE.
MITCHELL.
PAN.
HI. FIVE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
S. G. R. FOR SENATOR LEYVA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
PAN HI.
PRICE TWENTY FIVE KNOWS EIGHT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
SB ONE TWENTY EIGHT BELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY NUMBER. FIVE TWENTY FOUR NO
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SB
TWO TO THREE SENATOR HILL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI.
HI IS TWENTY EIGHT NO THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS --
FORTY FOUR FORTY THREE FORTY
THREE IS IT ANY OF ANY MEMBER
ONCE OF THE ISSUE PULLED THEY
NEED TO DO IT NOW.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY THREE THIRTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE AND SOME CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
FORTY PLEASE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA BY ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
BY DORADO.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI.
JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY.
BY WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
HI HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
[inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL IT
THE THE ROLE ONE MORE TIME FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MR SCHECK TERRY PLEASE CALL
DOUBTS MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
ATKINS FOR JUST I GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
MITCHELL. FIVE THIRTY THREE NO
ZERO THIS SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AT THIS TIME LIKE TO CALL ON
COMMITTEE CHAIRS TO ANNOUNCE
COMMITTEE -- CALENDAR FOR TODAY.
CENTER Y. CASKEY.
MISTER PRESIDENT THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE REVIEW ON NATURAL
RESOURCES ENVIRO PROTECTION
ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION WILL
CONVENE IN ROOM ONE ONE TWO AT
THE AT TEN THIRTY FIVE ONE ONE
TWO EIGHT TEN THIRTY FIVE THANK
YOU SENATOR ROSS.
THANK YOU AS PRESIDENT TO BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATION WILL CONVENE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AT TEN
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU SIR SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
THE BHAJAN FISCAL.
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WILL CONVENE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE AT TEN FORTY THANK YOU
SIR CENTER SKINNER.
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY WILL MEET IN ROOM
ONE THIRTEEN FIFTEEN MINUTES
AFTER THE FLOOR ADJOURNS.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
OF SENATOR ROBB SO THANK YOU --
SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR WILL
MEET IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THIS MEETING.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WILL BE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO ADDRESS A
TURN IN MEMORIES FROM ANY
SENATOR.
CENTER CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
YOU SORT OF WANT TO BELIEVE THAT
YOU -- WILL HAVE YOUR PARENTS
FOREVER YOU FEEL LIKE YOU WILL
LIVE WITH THEM.
FOREVER AND MY FATHER AND I JOKE
QUITE A BIT ABOUT HOW HE WAS
GOING TO MAKE IT.
TO ONE HUNDRED AND AFTER SERVING
AS A A YEARS ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WHEN I WAS DONE IT
WAS LIKE I'M SO GLAD I NEVER HAD
TO DO AN ADJOURNMENT FOR ONE OF
MY FOLKS.
AND HERE I AM ON THE SENATE
FLOOR AND I WAS I WAS TRAVELING
TO THE AIRPORT LAST THURSDAY.
I GOT THE TEXT FROM MY SISTER
THAT MY FATHER.
HAD PASSED AWAY -- HE WAS NINETY
ONE YEARS OLD.
HE WOULD.
HAVE PARKS -- NON HODGKINS.
LYMPHOMA AND THAT CREATED BLOOD
CLOTS PULMONARY EMBOLISM
[inaudible]
AND HE WENT TO BE WITH JESUS IN
HEAVEN ON THURSDAY AFTERNOON.
FIVE I WAS THANKFUL I HAD A
CHANCE TO FLY.
THE DENVER A COUPLE WEEKS AGO TO
THANK HIM FOR RAISING ME
[inaudible]
AND TO THANK YOU BYE TO MY DAD.
HE WAS BORN CLASS MEINDERT MORAL
ARC.
IN THE NETHERLANDS ON OCTOBER.
TWENTY SEVEN NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN HE WAS THE SECOND OF SIX
SIBLINGS.
HE WOULDN'T YOUR **** OCCUPATION
DURING WORLD WAR.
TWO AND I COULD TELL PROBABLY
STORIES TELL THE INTO THE NIGHT.
ON WHAT SUFFERING THAT WAS.
AFTER THE WAR AND WIFE SETTLE
DOWN HE ATTENDED ARRESTS MISS
UNIVERSITY IN ROTTERDAM WHERE HE
EARNED A DOCTOR AND AS AN
ECONOMICS WITH DISTINCTION.
AND EVEN TO THIS DAY ARREST MRS
ONE OF THE TOP UNIVERSITIES IN
EUROPE.
HE MARRIED MY MOTHER WE GET THE
UNIT CORNELIA DEVORE WHO.
WAS BORN ON I AM MARRIED HER ON
AUGUST TWENTY SEVEN NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE AND SHE WAS NUMBER
SIX OF SEVEN SIBLINGS.
THEY WOULD HAVE TWO CHILDREN.
IN THE NETHERLANDS MYSELF AND MY
BROTHER EDWARD.
BEFORE THE IMMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES IN. NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE OF THREE OF MY MOTHER'S
BROTHERS HAD ALREADY EMIGRATED
TO THE UNITED STATES AND EDWARD
THE BORE.
MY MOTHER'S.
BROTHER WAS OUR SPONSOR AND HE
WOULD.
IN THE LATE SIXTIES ACTUALLY RUN
SUCCESSFULLY FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY REPUBLICAN CENTRAL
COMMITTEE WORRY SERVE WITH.
WALTER NOT OF KNOTS BERRY FARM
FAME.
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A SEAT WHEN
I WAS A YOUNG PERSON FOR WHERE I
AM.
TODAY.
MY FOLKS AMERICANIZED THEIR
NAMES TO CANTON RITA AND MINE TO
JOHN AND THEY WOULD HAVE TO MORE
CHILDREN CAN'T MICHAEL IN A
MEMORY.
MY DAD LEFT -- HIS SUCCESSFUL
FAMILY BUSINESS IN THE GRAIN
INDUSTRY SO IF YOU EVER GO TO
NORTHERN HALL AND YOU'LL SEE THE
MORE LIVE MAIL FOR BRICK -- SORT
OF THE BIGGEST BUSINESS IN TOWN
IT'S A FLOUR MILL IN THE CITY
ABOUT HER IS HER MAIDEN.
BUT HERE IN THE STATES HE WENT
INTO THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY --
AND ATTAINED THE CHARTERED LIFE
UNDERWRITER OR THE SEAL U.
DESIGNATION.
HE WAS AN AGENT FOR PENN MUTUAL
LIFE INSURANCE COMPANY WHERE HE
WAS A COLLEAGUE WITH DAVID ****.
WHO WOULD LATER BECOME A
CALIFORNIA SOME WOMEN IN SENATOR
AND FOR WHOM THE **** LOUNGE?
IS NAMED AND SO WHEN I WAS
TREASURER OF THE COUNTY I ALWAYS
COME UP AND ALWAYS BE GREETED.
SO NICELY BY DAVID **** SO IT IS
SO NICE TO SEE HIS PHOTO.
IN THE LOUNGE BECAUSE HE WAS
JUST A A DEAR MAN.
MY DAD ALSO SOLD PROPERTY AND
CASUALTY INSURANCE AND PRETTY
MUCH SOLD WITHIN THE DUTCH
COMMUNITY -- FLOWER ARTESIA
NORWALK PARAMOUNT LE PALM AND
ALL THE WAY.
THE CHINO WERE MOST THE DAIRYMAN
STARTED TO MOVE TO WHEN I WAS
YOUNGER -- HE HE WAS.
IT WAS A BUSY MAN STARTING ALL
OVER AND SO I WOULD ALWAYS WILL
MINIMIZE MY DAD SO BUSY WHY
DON'T WANT ONLY.
YOU DON'T SEE A MUCH IT HERE I
AM LIKE BUSY.
BUT HE INSTILLED LOVES IN ME AT
HE TOOK US TO THE BEACH I MEAN.
WE WERE KIDS YOU KNOW THE THE
PACIFIC OCEAN IS A WHOLE LOT
BETTER THAN THE NORTH SEA.
YOU KNOW YOU GOTTA WAVES AND AND
IT'S JUST IT'S A GREAT MOVIE GO
TO BOTH THE CHEEK ON SUNDAY
AFTERNOONS.
HE WOULD TAKE US TO THE SLOPES
MY DAD WHEN HE WAS IN COLLEGE
WOULD GO TO THE AUSTRIAN ALPS IN
SKI IN THE WINTERTIME AND SO HE
BROUGHT US TO A MOUNT BALDY BACK
IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE THAT'S
WHEN I STARTED SNOW SKIING HERE
LOCALLY IN.
AND AND THEN HE WOULD TAKE US
ALL OVER -- ANYWAY TAKE US ON
TRAILS SO HE TOOK US TO THE TOP
OF MOUNT ST YOU'RE GOING YOU
KNOW THE HIGHEST MOUNTAIN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TOOK US THE
TOP OF MOUNT BALDY ARE.
MOUNT SAN ANTONIO THE TECHNICAL
NAME ONE OF THE MORE MEMORABLE
TRIP TRIPS WAS A HIKING TO THE
TOP OF MOUNT WHITNEY IN THE
SIERRAS AND ONE OF THE MOST
AMAZING TRIPS WAS ACTUALLY
HIKING TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
GRAND CANYON WE WERE TEENAGERS --
GOING TO PHANTOM RANCH.
BUT HE WOULD JOIN ME SAID THAT
STARTED IN THE ANNUAL BACKPACK
TRIP BY BE SUMMER EVERY.
SEPTEMBER MY DAD HIKE WITH US
FOR A LONG TIME FOR YEARS HE
WOULD SAY LET ME START BEFORE
YOU GUYS START.
AND HE WOULD GO UP THE TRAIL WE
MEET HIM AT THE CAMP.
WAS IT DRIVES UP AND DOWN THREE
NINETY FIVE TO MAMMOTH.
WHEN WE WOULD SKI IN THE WINTER
THAT I WOULD SEE ALL THESE
HISTORICAL LANDMARK SIGNS FIVE
HUNDRED YARDS AHEAD OR WHATEVER
AND SO THAT STARTED A HOBBY OF
VISITING EVERY HISTORICAL
LANDMARK?
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT HIS FOCUS WAS WORLD WAR.
TWO AND IT DIDN'T TAKE US TO
NORMAL MOVIES HE WOULD TAKE A
STEP TOWARD TOWARD TORAH OR THE
LONGEST DAY OR PATENT WAS.
THAT WAS WHAT MY DAD WATCHING SO
MEMBER NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE IN
MY SENIOR YEAR IN HIGH SCHOOL
STARTING COLLEGE EVERY SUNDAY
NIGHT WE HAD WATCH WORLD AT WAR
WHICH WAS A SERIES BACK THEN IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THAT WAS
JUST SUCH A FOCAL POINT FOR MY
DAD.
BUT ONE OF THE FUN THINGS ABOUT
MY DAD WAS THAT HE TALKED TO
EVERYBODY.
YEAH HE WAS VERY RIGOROUSLY IN
COMPLETE STRANGERS ANY WITH
ENGAGE IN.
AND SOMETIMES WE GO.
WHAT'S TO NETWORK RIGHT IF YOU
KNOW THESE PEOPLE.
IT WAS SORT OF A RUNNING KIND OF
THING BUT HERE WE ARE AS ADULTS
TALKING TO EVERYONE AND HAVING
FUN.
AND THEN FOR SOME OF US WITHOUT
SOMETIMES YOU MAYBE MAYBE HE WAS
A LITTLE DISTANT WHEN WE WERE.
TOGETHER BUT I THINK THAT MADE
IS FIRSTLY INDEPENDENT THIS FOR
KIDS -- HE RAISED US IN THE
DUTCH REFORMED CHURCH OF AMERICA
THE RCA SO WE WERE RAISED IN A
CHRISTIAN HOME A GREAT CHURCH.
BUT WITH THAT HE HE SORT OF HAD
AN ABRAHAM ASPECT OF HIS LIFE HE
HE SAID THAT -- WHEN ABRAHAM WAS
TOLD BY GOD YOU KNOW LEAVE LEAVE
AND GO TO A LAND THAT I WILL
SHOW YOU -- THAT THAT SEEMS TO
BE SOMETHING THAT WAS EMBEDDED
MY FATHER TO BECAUSE LEAVING.
YOU KNOW A GREAT JOB A GREAT
BUSINESS A GREAT LOCATION AND
AND STARTING ALL OVER WAS A BIG
DEAL -- BUT BUT IT WAS A MODEL
FOR ME BECAUSE I LEFT A
PARTNERSHIP THAT I SHOULD HAVE
BEEN IN.
FOR MY WHOLE LIFE FOR CPA
PRACTICE TO VENTURE OUT INTO
PUBLIC LIFE IN IT.
CERTAINLY GAVE MY SISTER THE
ABILITY TO GO.
TO TAKE A JOB TRANSFER TO
COLORADO WHERE SHE WITHIN METER
HUSBAND IN A NEW LAND AND RAISE
HER FAMILY THERE.
AND MY BROTHER CAN'T WENT ON TO
TAKE A A CALL IN A CHURCH IN
TENNESSEE AND HE MADE THE BIG
MOVE TO TENNESSEE AS WELL SO.
MY DAD WAS A BUT YOU KNOW OUR
MODEL AND TAKING THE LEAP INTO A
LAND THAT GOD WOULD SHOW
[inaudible]
IN CLOSING.
I'M GLAD I'M HOLDING UP REALLY
WELL.
MY DAD IS SIR BYE BYE MY MOTHER.
AND HIS FOUR KIDS AND THEIR
SPOUSES THIRTEEN GRANDCHILDREN
FOUR GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND HIS
MEMORIAL SERVICE WILL BE APRIL
THIRTEENTH AT ELEVEN AM AT
CHRIST COMMUNITY CHURCH WAS
FORMALLY COMMUNITY REFORM CHURCH
WHERE I GREW UP IN ACTUALLY WERE
I MARRIED MY WIFE TRINA.
BUT I I WANT -- TO THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES -- FOR YOUR YOUR KIND
WORDS NOTES EMAILS [inaudible]
CARDS TAX.
BUT CONDOLENCES AT MY FAMILY'S
TIME OF LOS I'M.
REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
BEING FAMILY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SIR MORE LIKE ABOUT
HALF THE ENTIRE SENATE WE WE
SEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY [inaudible]
SENATE ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY IN HEY IN MEMORY OF
A NINE YEAR OLD GIRL.
WHO WAS MURDERED?
IN MY DISTRICT.
OF HACIENDA HEIGHTS.
I REYES TO I RISE TO JOINER
EDURNE IN HER MEMORY.
BECAUSE SHE WAS.
A LITTLE GIRL WHO -- WAS SO
PRECIOUS TO HER. TO SO MANY WHO
NEWER.
BUT SHE WAS A VICTIM OF MURDER.
HER NAME IS TRINITY LOVED JONES.
A NINE YEAR OLD LITTLE GIRL
WHOSE BODY WAS FOUND ON MARCH
FIFTH AT HACIENDA HEIGHTS.
I WAS FORTUNATE TO ARRIVE.
SOON -- YOUR INDIVIDUAL I GOT
OUT OF THE PLANE.
RAN OVER THERE THERE WAS HUNDRED
PEOPLE THERE AND HACIENDA
HEIGHTS.
ALL CARRYING CANDLES. TO A
DOLLARS THAT THIS LITTLE GIRL.
WHO THEY REALLY DIDN'T KNOW IF
SHE WAS FROM HACIENDA HEIGHTS
AWARE SHE BUT FROM?
BUT EVERYONE KNEW THAT LITTLE
GIRL HAD BEEN FOUND.
IN A DUFFEL BAG THROWN BY THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD.
AND SHE WAS WEARING A PINK SAUCE
SWEATSHIRT.
AND ON THE SWEATSHIRT IT SAID
FUTURE PRINCES HERO.
SO AT THAT MOMENT EVERYONE REFER
TO AS PART OF A HERO.
AND I A HUG DIDN'T AND CRIED
WITH SOME OF THE PEOPLE THERE
WHO DIDN'T EVEN KNOW SHE WAS.
BUT SHE WAS PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY A DIVERSE COMMUNITY.
AND IT WAS LATER FOUND THAT SHE
WAS MURDERED [inaudible]
AND THE BURGERS HAVE BEEN
APPREHENDED.
BUT WITH A BROKEN HEART.
WE LEARNED FINALLY HER NAME.
AND THAT WAS.
TRINITY CLUB JONES NINE YEARS
OLD.
AND THE COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
SADDENED -- WE WILL MISS HER
DEARLY.
AND HER FATHER.
CRIED AND CRIED.
WHEN?
IT WAS DISCOVERED IT WAS HER
DAUGHTER.
AND THESE THINGS GO ON
THROUGHOUT THIS COUNTRY.
WE MUST.
LOOK TO OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
QUICKLY FIND AND APPREHEND THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND I WAS SO PROUD
OF THE LOS ANGELES SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
WHEN I TALK TO THEM AND THEY
THEY PUT THIS ON TOP PRIORITY?
AND THEY HAVE BEEN APPREHENDED.
SO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I ASK
TODAY THAT WE JOIN WITH ME IN
MORNING TRADE UP JONES JUST NINE
YEAR OLD GIRL.
WHO FOR SOME TIME HAD NO NAME
BUT WE NOW KNOW OUR IS OUR
LITTLE PRINCESS SO I WOULD LIKE
TO ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SAID ARCHULETA AND
CONDOLENCES GO OUT TO TO HER
FAMILY AND AND ALL INVOLVED IN
YOUR COMMUNITY.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
BEFORE US SENATOR MCGUIRE THE
DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT WONDERFUL JOB TODAY
AND I KNOW ON BEHALF OF PROTEIN
MACINNES DEEP CONDOLENCES TO
SENATOR MORLOCK.
WE HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND AND TAKE SOME
TIME TO REMEMBER THE WONDERFUL
LIFE AND LEGACY IN WORK OF CESAR
CHAVEZ TOMORROW.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
MADE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT
TWO PM [inaudible]
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU CENTER CHOIR AGAIN THE
SENATE WILL BE IN REST RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM.
AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE MADE AND WE WILL
RECONVENE BACK HERE MONDAY APRIL
FIRST TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
AT TWO PM HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND
MEMBERS